vamos a tratar de introducirnos con una
definición que es matemáticamente
rigurosa de lo que este diagrama muestra
presenta así que pensemos que el límite
de fx cuando x se aproxima a c es igual
a l y lo que esto nos quiere decir es
que puedes obtener es que puedes obtener
f x tan cerca de l tan cerca de l como
tú quieras y voy a poner entre comillas
tan cerca como tú quieras porque
simplemente me estoy tratando de referir
de una forma más sencilla a lo que
quiero llegar haciendo que x esté lo
suficientemente cerca lo suficientemente
cerca desea
en otras palabras esto es que si tú me
dices hey yo que quiero obtener mi f x
con un punto 5 de este límite o sea nos
estamos refiriendo a un rango a un rango
que se acerque a dicho límite y si este
límite es realmente cierto serás capaz
de mostrarme decirme el valor alrededor
de c
es x dentro de un rango donde f x
definitivamente quedará muy cerca de x
como yo lo desee así que ahora vamos a
hacer las cosas más claras en otro
diagrama vamos a hacer una especie de
acercamiento o zoom para que esto se vea
más claro entonces este es nuestro eje
de leyes y este sería nuestro eje de la
vez más derechito con una especie de
acercamiento en nuestro eje de las x
nuestro eje de las x se encuentra aquí y
nuestro eje de la vez y bueno voy a
dibujar un tanto más clara la función
porque nos queremos concentrar en el
intervalo y digamos que aquí se
encuentra se y dándole un tanto efecto
de zoom o acercamiento a la función
digamos que se vería luciría algo así y
aquí voy a dejar un breve espacio para
definir lo que vamos a dejar de de
límite porque como nosotros sabemos un
límite está indefinido entonces este
espacio que está por aquí sería lo que
representaría
espero haberlo trazado como como luce
arriba y aquí es cuando x es igual a c
entonces aquí se encontraría lo del
límite indefinido y esto sería un
pequeño pliegue y bueno espero que quede
claro que la línea que acabo detrás
ahora aquí punteada es de cuando x es
igual a c y entonces esta gráfica
acabamos de trazar es igual a fx y lo
que queremos es entender el límite
queremos entender el límite de fx cuando
x se aproxima a c y éste va a ser igual
aire entonces conceptualmente tenemos ya
lo esencial entonces esto de aquí nos va
a representar a l por lo que acabamos de
definir pero en realidad que es lo que
nos quiere decir nos dice bueno puedes
obtener fx tan cerca de l como tú
quieras tan cerca como tú quieras
entonces si le dijeras a alguien oye yo
quiero obtener quiero obtener f x con un
cierto rango de l luego si dicho el
límite es realmente cierto el límite
efe de x cuando x se aproxima a c es
igual a l entonces yo luego debería de
encontrar un rango alrededor de c y
dicho rango va a ser tan largo como x es
alrededor de fx y esto va a ser el rango
que prácticamente tú quieras entonces
déjame pensar en cómo podríamos
realmente interpretar esto como un juego
hagamos de cuenta que tú estás situado
en algún lugar y que alguien viene cerca
de ti y que quizás tú quieres poner un
límite en el cual haya como un intervalo
de espacio pero por supuesto que en este
caso de la vida real esto va a ser igual
a l porque va a haber un punto que
quizás y te pueda tocar pero no estoy
segura de que sea realmente el caso que
quiero representar entonces mejor vamos
a darle un rango de punto 5 entonces acá
tenemos el menos punto 5 y el de arriba
sería l más punto 5 y luego entonces
decimos si tomo un x con dicho rango
entonces fx va a caer siempre en el
rango que tenemos por acá y bueno aquí
vamos a definirlo y especificar lo para
función y debes de tener en cuenta que
aunque este camino luce un tanto fácil
de entender no es igual de sencillo para
todas las funciones entonces digamos que
este punto que acabamos de trazar por
aquí que esto que acabamos de pasar por
aquí va a ser c - punto 25 y el de por
acá va a ser igual a c va a ser igual
hace más punto 25 entonces ahora tú
dirás hey mira aquí ya se ve más claro
como tan largos tu propusiste los x
conforme se acercaban hace y van
tendiendo hacia el límite que propusimos
la fbi que ya se iba acercando cada vez
más a él entonces corresponden a fx y
van a caer en el rango que nosotros
propusimos y luego qué tal si se te
ocurre a decirme oye pero en realidad yo
lo quiero de un sentido más estricto
entonces en lugar de proponer está el en
más punto cinco y que cayera por acá y
la elementos punto cinco que fuera de
estricta forma entonces al hacer el
procedimiento este límite tendría que
ser verdad podríamos ser capaces de
imaginar
este procedimiento y encontrar cualquier
rango diferente al que yo te vi de forma
particular cualquier rango que alguien
te dijera podría ser capaz de
encontrarlo y también ser capaz de
encontrar fx dentro de este rango
alrededor de c entonces seremos bien
capaces de encontrar cualquier rango
alrededor de él y todo lo demás que
nosotros realizamos para saber que este
límite en efecto es realmente cierto
entonces en el siguiente vídeo nos vamos
a enfocar en generalizar lo para
cualquier forma entonces esto nos
traería consigo la forma o la definición
con epsilon y ventas de los límites